welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian just released
new footage from its upcoming second
season in a new teaser trailer along
with some
huge but easy to overlook easter eggs
there is
so much to break down i got you covered
though i've gotten real good at reading
baby otis facial expressions
that base means he's hungry it's usually
hunger
let's roll it
you have something i want
it will be mine
okay real quick here we are seeing old
footage from season one but recolored in
a blue gray color palette
that shifts into a warmer tone as mando
and the razor crest approached this new
ice planet in season two i love how even
with this
frosty surface you can still feel the
warmer tones telling us we have arrived
to the present
i believe this new planet is ilum the
ice planet mined for kyber crystals that
are used to power lightsabers
later turn into starkiller base by the
first order in the force awakens but
that's still decades away
presently we are still just five years
or so after returning the jedi i do
appreciate how this new season seems to
have a diverse mix of temperatures in
their settings
fiery hot lava cool water and ice
nice we see the final shot of season one
moff gideon scaring off some jawas from
his crashed outland tie fighter with the
darksaber the sacred ancient blade of
the mandalorian people
he must have snatched that from bo katan
last seen wielding it at the end of star
wars rebels we're assuming that happened
with the
purge he referred to last season has
heard the songs of the siege of
mandalore
when gunships outfitted with similar
ordinance
laid waste to fields of mandalorian
recruits in the night
of a thousand tears now a live-action
version of bogota will be played by
katie sakhoff this season and rosario
dawson will explain
live action ahsoka tano still no
sighting of her in this footage though
we did see a
hooded sasha banks believed to be sabine
wren
ahsoka's most recent traveling companion
giancarlo esposito promised there would
be some
lightsaber duel in this season i think
i'm off gideon with the darksaber ahsoka
with her blade though
not necessarily representing the jedi
orders since remember in clone wars
she parted ways for the jedi order i'm
thinking mop gideon could be an
imperial moth obsessed with jedi culture
and relics
thus his fascination with a dark saber
and with a new member of mystery species
of
the great yoda let's move on to the new
new stuff
the mandalorian okay there is some
interesting new stuff to break down here
well before i continue i want to thank
our friends at raid shadow legends for
sponsoring this video making these kinds
of breakdowns possible for us and giving
me an amazing game that i can dive into
whenever i want
raid shadow legends has 500 champions
each with their own skill trees
and millions of artifacts to find and
equip doing some numbers that
is probably trillions of ways to build
your teams and endless strategies to
deploy
see here i'm going to the index i'm
going to look at some of the different
options for the banner lords
oh look at this bell flower she's a got
a nice little ascot and
you can never have so many belts every
day you play the game you get
great login rewards that help you
progress faster in the game battle head
to head with other players in the pvp
arena where you can spend arena tokens
to move up tears
and earn extra rewards win the best
artifacts by fighting in the dungeons
where you'll battle bosses
and get some sweet artifact cargo every
three days exciting tournaments and
events take place in rage shadow legends
take part in these tournaments to earn
cool in-game rewards and new in raid
they just released the new advanced
quest system and the artifact forge
where you can make your own artifacts
and very excited about this are about to
release the
doom tower click the link in the
description for the marathon that
introduces new players to the game's
mechanics
just go to the video description click
on these special links and if you're a
new player you will get
100 thousand silver and one free
champion this badass guys
slasher who both looks cool and will
help you a bunch early in the game all
this treasure will be waiting for you
up here oh and if you need advice you
are not alone subscribe to the guide on
the telaria world and find out the whole
truth about raid shadow legends link in
the description good luck and i'll see
you there
okay back to the trailer mando enters
the fighting arena with these two
sparring gamoreans i've pointed out
before how this appears to match the
exterior shots of the
graffiti cover town where mando passes a
jawa eyeing him from the shadows and
lassoes up a tuscan raider to a
streetlight to
tell by its scream you can see all that
imperial graffiti which makes me think
this is tatooine which was staunchly
anti-imp
last season the gomorians and that biz
fortuna looking male twilic
in the deep background the other side of
the fighting ring suggests to me that we
could be looking at the remnants of the
gang of jabba the hutt
i mentioned this because there is a new
shot of cara dune rolling to her feet in
a
setting that looks a lot like jabba's
palace now canonically after jabba's
death tatooine's criminal operation was
taken over by the nicto cartels but in
the new season footage the boss seems to
be the jon favreau voiced gord koresh
you know this is no place for a child
wherever i go he goes
so i've heard so mando and baby oda are
returning to tatooine maybe
to recapture phoenix shand from the
mystery figure at the end of episode 5
last season and this is most likely how
they will cross paths with
boba fett this season who is confirmed
to return after
being swallowed by tatooine sarlacc in
return of the jedi i did break down some
major
possible boba fett clues in another
video you're definitely going to want to
check it out now the character posters
they just released for
mando baby yoda greek karga and cara
dune are all set in front of that same
tattooing graffiti on grief's poster
there is an image of an
aqualish with a red circle crossing them
out this is most likely a nod to panda
baba that
jerk picking bar fights with luke
skywalker and tatooine's maz eisley
cantina
[Music]
[Applause]
or maybe you know this graffiti could
have just been put up to caution other
aqualish like
don't drink at this place crazy old
wizards will cut off your hand we also
see that boat on the water planet that
many are thinking could be mon cala home
world of admiral akbar and the other mod
calamari i do love how you can see baby
oda's ear flapping in the wind there
it's like he's waving at us but behind
them are a few
quarren sailors one of them looking
tired maybe a little
seasick though i guess that'd be a bit
weird since he's part fish so
boat sick i don't know maybe we'll get a
character moment from this guy
a crusty sailor tail or a sea shanty i
tell ya
the opie's got black eyes like a doll's
eyes
another new shot shows doors opening on
cara dune mando and grief karga now the
bulkheads behind them
match those these stormtroopers run past
i'm thinking this could be also on that
new
star destroyer jean carlos posito teased
for this season and since baby odin with
a maybe it's a baby out of rescue
operation
i do love how he secret karga in the
gunners seat perhaps out of the razor
crest
obviously echoing the dogfight on the
millennium falcon in a new hope
hopefully carl weathers learns a lesson
from the sequel movies when you blow
something up don't
whoo don't get cocky
give a little yeehaw if you want they
always do a little yeehaw like a cowboy
good enough more outland tie fighters
take off but it is later in the shot
than the last time we saw this shot now
we could see a lava explosion
behind them we have seen a lava river in
other shots of storm troopers on speeder
bikes so we might be seeing an
imperial base on navarro which does have
lava pools and rivers
some are saying it could also be the
volcanic surface of sullust homeworld of
the celestines like
but i don't know i'm feeling navarro
another shot shows mando jetpacking off
a platform but now we see that platform
is at the edge of rising lava in a
crater
yikes who would build a base here and
our final shot here shows mando's
superhero landon besides some
unconscious stormtroopers
and it looks like the same airfield that
the outlander ties just took off from so
this could be yet another mission to
strike this imperial lava base if this
is navarro it could explain a lot about
why
imperial loyalists had such a presence
on this planet because as we saw in
episode six last season the new republic
are the new sheriffs in town
as we saw on tatooine the imps aren't
welcome everywhere interestingly we just
learned from a variety report that pedro
pascal and the rest of the cast and crew
plan to begin production for season
three
before the end of 2020 so it is full
steam ahead on this show especially as
disney announced they are shifting their
focus to more streaming content and we
got confirmation the mandalorian will
release weekly every friday all the way
through december 18th
also big announcement from us not only
will i break down each episode of the
mandalorian season 2 to point out all
the star wars easter eggs that you might
have missed new rockstars is going to be
releasing our same day
mandalorian after show wookie leaks with
tommy bechtold and i
sharing our immediate thoughts and our
favorite videos moments
those will be coming out every friday
here on youtube and on the podcast feed
called wikileaks subscribe to it if you
aren't already but if you already
subscribed to wikileaks last year or if
you subscribe to our boys underground
feed it is the same bead so you're
already there but do us a favor and
leave us a positive rating and reviews
so that'll help our listing get more
ears on this
you can also discuss your thoughts and
theories on the mandalorian with us
on new rockstar's official discord
server which you can access by becoming
a patron at patreon.comrockstars
subscribe to the rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
ea boss follow new rockstar thank you
for watching and hey special shout out
to my cousin noah in hattiesburg
mississippi
thank you for being awesome and watching
these buddy to any of the doubters in
his friend group noah and i
are related though to all the other
people asking out there i am not related
to jim gaffigan i don't know why people
keep saying that we just
share a love of pot pockets
[Music]
you